je ne sais pas s'il doit la retrouver
parce que je ne sais pas si la lune il
ya eu une jambe gauche un jour et les
électeurs de gauche pour emmanuel macron
c'est vrai et même pour le deuxième tour
de l'élection présidentielle nombreux
pour voter contre le front national en
revanche est ce qu'il ya derrière une
jambe gauche à vie à la politique d'
emmanuel macron je ne suis pas raciste
je n'en suis pas sûr et pour tout dire
ça fait longtemps que je pense que s'il
existe une jambe gauche c'est une jambe
de bois
mais je ne l'espérais pas non plus il a
fait un discours très clair à la sai
lundi dernier il a été extrêmement
limpide dans l'esprit qui l'animent
c'est un libéral il n'y a rien à
attendre de cette politique là pour ceux
qui cherchent qui espère un deuxième
temps de gauche il a dit les choses
il a dit - les inégalités c'est pas mon
problème je me bats uniquement contre
les inégalités de destin donc quand j'ai
fait mon boulot sur l'école et la
formation c'est fini après c'est le
marché qui vous juge et vous êtes
inégaux c'est normal c'est pas un souci
pour moi après l'es10 il faut qu'ils
aient un gâteau pour qu'on puisse faire
partager mais il ya bien un gâteau qu'il
entend réaliser avec le pays mais il a
simplement enlevé le couteau pour
pouvoir partager il faut un couteau
derrière pour pouvoir répartir à parts
égales ou même à paris inégal
sauf que il détruit tous les outils du
partage du gâteau la politique fiscale
et sur les services publics et donc il
n'y aura pas de deuxième jambe parce que
il a remis entièrement le sort de la
france dans les mains du marché le rôle
de l'état prenne l macron c'est un état
qui fluidifie l'accès aux marchés car on
est en bas